foreign
[Music]
thank you
thank you thank you very much
thank you for being here
thank you for being here all right how's
this huh one more time for the Green
Mill everybody this place is
fantastic
what an honor to be doing this at the
Green Mill whoever said uh stand up
couldn't be cool
was right
but they did not know that I would be
shooting a special at the Green Mill and
calling it Top Gun 3.
uh it's good to see you guys good to be
out good to share your biology again huh
it was a while
it was a long couple years there
um I handled covet like I always handled
herpes
attested negative
and there's just no way that's right
no way
there's no way that's right just uh just
based on where I've been
based on where I've been I'm gonna say
those are false negatives
they say those are false negatives I'll
tell you this though if the vaccine was
for herpes we wouldn't be fighting like
this as a country
nobody be dragging their heels on the
herpes vaccine
0.0 U.S Americans are not getting
the herpes vaccine
Chicago nobody's walking off the job
because they don't want to get the
herpes vaccine
no firefighters are trading their
pensions for cold Source guys that's
what I'm trying to say
no no truck drivers are clogging up a
bridge because they're mad about the
herpes vaccine mandate
I don't know if you guys know any truck
drivers but they're gonna be the first
ones to get the herpes vaccine
10-4 good buddy I'll take 10 more for
all my favorite ladies at the gasoline
yard
[Laughter]
so them gals can get back to work
oh
that's good um
right before the pandemic I got my
identity theft
see take him
stolen married is what I meant I got
married
um
come on she's a wonderful woman well how
would you confuse those two things Nate
I don't know
it felt like a bit of a smash and grab I
gotta be honest
everything I thought I knew gone in an
instant
no she's wonderful she's a better person
than me my wife that's a risk
being with a better person than you you
know what I'm talking about
because now it's in my head every day I
wake up maybe she just did this because
I look like I needed help
[Laughter]
I don't need that kind of doubt in my
life
life do I gotta sandbag this if I get
functional does she
does she move on to the next town
like Bruce Banner
save some other elderly boy
I don't want to disappoint her but I
can't have her thinking her work here is
done
[Laughter]
laughs
every once in a while I suggest we get a
roommate
just to keep her on her toes
now you guys I'm sorry I do have to I
kind of got to power through this
tonight I I
finally got my booster shot and now I
can't feel my freedom uh
[Laughter]
thank you
[Applause]
I'm serious right when the needle hit my
skin
right when the needle hit my skin I
could feel my pocket Constitution burst
into flames
right there in my Banana Republic cargo
pants
[Laughter]
new set of cargo pants I lost a
perfectly good pair of outlet mall
tactical cargo pants
to that damn booster shot
right when the science was soaking into
my loins
I could feel my musket slip out of my
hands
right there into the Potomac
[Music]
because I went from Walgreens to the
Potomac
to apologize to the ghost of George
Washington
and he wouldn't look me in my eyes and I
panicked and I dropped my muscular
it floated to the bottom
where Rachel maddowell was waiting
[Laughter]
with her bony little mad owl fingers and
she caught my musket she kept it
not cool science
not cool
no good job science
proud of you but people aren't impressed
by science anymore
they're not impressed
start throwing curveball science
give them something to look at
here you go science you want to impress
me Give a Pig a person heart
[Laughter]
s
just one time science
huh did you ever even think you never
even thought about that
we're constantly giving people pig
hearts and what do they do they lay
around they sleep and eat they do a
bunch of Pig stuff yeah it's boring it's
boring
just one time make me a pick and do some
people stuff science
one time make me a pig that can join a
Climbing gym or
make me a pig I can enjoy a rom-com with
science
guys don't worry my wife is a nurse
which makes me a doctor and
[Laughter]
It's Been a Good Year
It's Been a Good Year to be a brand new
doctor
because I mean now more than ever we
need real medical professionals
now more than ever half the country got
phds on YouTube last year
so I'll fight that fight
somebody says some nonsense to me I'll
I'll look them straight in the face I'll
stack some I halfway listen to
right up on top of something else I
change the channel before they were done
explaining it
I'll push it right across the bar at
their ass call it research gotta call it
research
that way they know you didn't read it
people don't like it when you read some
that calls them to question their
work ethic then the whole conversation
is lost
I'll call it research to their
face and then they know
they're dealing with a medical
professional
[Laughter]
I hope everybody's okay I hope
everybody's okay
um did anybody else lose a family member
to Q Anon uh
the real pandemic
my name's Nate I'm from Wisconsin I was
born in Indiana through a tire swing so
foreign
this Q Anon is affecting me
directly uh
if you don't know what Q Anon is it's a
video game that
Hillbillies get to live inside of
and I was not prepared I was not
prepared I had never lost a cousin to
Super Mario Brothers before
but it is that's what it is it's a it's
Super Mario Brothers if the princess
we're supposed to save is my cousin's
wife
Mandy
tell me more Mandy everything I know
about Q Anon I know from Mandy's
Instagram story
yes I guess that uh the Democratic party
and the Hollywood Elite
which I am one of
[Laughter]
are running a baby huffing dungeon
where they Huff the steam off of babies
and they get that's how they get their
power that's
that's why Nancy Pelosi's Dentures look
like they're gonna eat her own face
every morning
just
snorting that hot hot baby Steam
also maybe in just real quick in defense
of baby huffing uh
is some of the country not huffing
babies it's
one of the finest things in life
I mean I don't even have kids I just any
chance I get to Huff a baby I'm doing it
and I I would just recommend it maybe
you'd calm down a little bit but anyway
no I will say this though uh I think the
pandemic was hardest on the whites
oh
because we already wanted to talk to the
manager
we already wanted to talk to the manager
and now everybody wanted to talk to the
manager of a sudden that line used to be
all ours
and now we had to do it through a mask
obviously we had to do it through a mass
we'd explain the Constitution we had to
we had to pretend that we read the
Constitution
threw a mask
while destroying a Beachwear display
to somebody that might not be the
manager
I mean we'll do it
we did it and we'll do it again
if that's what we have to do if that's
what we have to do to protect against
the things that our founding fathers
warned us against
we will leave no self-checkout screen
unslubbered upon
so that we can explain personal
sovereignty to somebody that just smoked
weed in a loading dock
thank you
that is what my people will do for you
you ever even thought about that
others
nobody wants to work anymore I want
everyone
I want everyone associated with this
decision fired
easy
nobody wants to work anymore
nobody wants to help you
[Laughter]
just don't be the biggest
at BevMo and
you're good you want people to help you
just
yeah
just be in line in front of that guy and
they'll do everything that you need
person
this person to know
carry your plastic
to have four for you buddy
[Applause]
and told me that on Instagram
nobody wants to work anymore
nobody went get back to work thanks Kim
thanks Kim really appreciate it wrong
messenger you know what I mean wrong
messenger what oh thank you Kim what
happened Kim did nobody help you at the
implant Warehouse
do you have any more opinions you can
help us through this
the current landscape of corporate
servitude Kim what are your opinions on
automation Kim
third of my dick
[Laughter]
that Kim Kardashian never changed a
vacuum back but
get in there Kim fight the good fight
let us know your thoughts on
mechanization when you get a shot
oh
thanks very much for coming out you guys
especially parents you guys had you did
the heavy lifting in that pandemic
yeah you really did I appreciate you
I appreciate you
I don't know I'd uh
anybody else without kids did you guys
call your
did you guys call your friends with kids
during the pandemic
oh man just chaos it was chaos
my buddy Ari this guy he was a
stay-at-home dad during the pandemic
he's got a three-year-old and a
five-year-old and I would call him and
just every call was just every call
sounded like he had called 9-1-1 and
dropped the phone
sir
and he would answer too right because he
was it was all day for him and he was
like oh dude dude what's up
dude hold on are you bleeding
Sadie no Sadie Sadie no no no
no not now no no no no no no no go with
your sister then just go with your
sister this is her for a second just go
with your sister buddy Stadium hold on
your brother's coming your brother's
coming Sadie wait up go with your sister
and then it's juice time and then it's
juice time and then it's juice time yes
thank you and then or I cancel juice
time do I have to cancel juice time or
do I have to cancel juice time then
yeah I didn't think so I didn't think so
hold on dude I got
bro I got Cheerios I don't even buy
Cheerios there's Cheerios
in every car I got say hey
wait for your brothers hey man hold up
dude I'm at Whole Foods I gotta call you
back
[Applause]
and I would listen to the whole call I
mean I was
you could drop the phone in his minivan
I'd be in my garage with no
responsibilities just like oh my God
smoking weed like what's gonna happen to
Sade
[Laughter]
tune in next week to see if Sadie gets
her juice
I think I'd be a good dad
[Laughter]
it's almost hurtful foreign
I know it's not something a good person
has to say
my worst fear is getting a kid stuck in
a ceiling fan
[Laughter]
you ever do that
you're a tall guy you never Jam a kid up
on a ceiling fan
never once wow what do you got
a nice high lofted ceilings in your
condo that you own
[Laughter]
convenient nobody ever rents their
ceiling fans anymore I'm the only one
I'm the only one with six foot five inch
ceiling fans just perfect
there he is my boy
Lewis not even born yet he's already got
a 16 inch scar above his left eye
I think I'm a good person
get a kid stuck in a ceiling fan it's a
bad time to find out you're not a good
person
I just don't I think I'll adopt
get like a 16 year old yeah
you agree with me
it's a good strategy get them across the
Finish Line real quick
pick one with a scholarship you know
you laugh because it's a foolproof plan
I just don't ever want to have to get an
infant through an airport
that looks like rock bottom
[Laughter]
you ever see two adults at the airport
just getting lapped
by one little organ grinder monkey off
its leash
grabbing snacks and harassing federal
agents
they're just Tangled Up In charger
cables with no words left getting a
divorce in silence just
[Laughter]
fighting over whose turn it is in
silence
you ever see an actually outnumbered
adult at the airport that's rock bottom
so Mom trying to get three kids through
security she just
quit in her eyes just it's a dead look
in her eyes she was just she was kicking
she was
challenging TSA agent she looked like
she wanted to get arrested huh
kicking a bear through the swiper ma'am
you can't
huh what who what these yeah they're
mine
this one's got a bomb in her huh
he's got a gun she's got a bomb do we
got to go somewhere to her
to a room with a couch take me to that
yeah I'll go take me to the room with
the couch where I can close my eyes for
the first time in 18 calendar months
I think I'll go to the couch room now
huh
how about the couch room
no I did not pack my own bags two brown
men I didn't recognize did that
couch room now
[Applause]
I don't know
I do my my wife says I'm not nice
fine
I'm a good person it can't be both
it's disgusting
excuse you're a good person doesn't mean
you have to be nice and just because
you're nice does not mean you're a good
person
the rudest thing anybody ever said to me
was I'll pray for you
[Laughter]
best thing to say to someone
if you know they believe what you
believe
but if they don't believe what you
I'll pray for you
it's a threat
I'll pray for you I'm gonna pray for you
I'll pray that's okay don't worry about
that no I'll pray for you no I'm gonna
pray for you I mean it's not gonna work
you're gonna be downstairs you're gonna
be bound up some sort of Trapped in some
sort of haunt you're gonna haunt some
building someday you're gonna be in Hell
For Eternity you're gonna not like your
life you're the attorney that was chosen
for you based on your behavior and your
and your demon-like Temptations that's
it's going it's gonna it's gonna be a
bad situation I'm gonna be upstairs I'm
gonna be getting I'm gonna be up up in a
different place than you but I'll pray
for you I'm gonna be getting a foot rub
in Heaven by whatever slaves they have
up there but
I'll pray for you
no thanks I got kicked out of Sunday
School
no the rudest thing anybody ever said
that somebody told me I had resting
face
[Music]
first of all uh maybe we take it easy on
our
[Laughter]
[Applause]
they're resting uh
how would you like it if every time you
tried to take a nap somebody compared
you to unhappy people
also why are you so familiar with what
resting look like
you'd be spying on
maybe these should be worried
about what you look like
maybe these should be describing
nap time creep face to the authorities
yeah I did get kicked out of Sunday
School uh that shit's on my resume
foreign
I grew up in a cathedral
um
I was just there all my dad was a I did
not sleep there
my dad was the choir director
at uh saint rayfield's
Cathedral where I'm from it's Saint
Raphael's
but if you're
if you're from Wisconsin it's I just
found this out I just realized this
I just realized that it was only because
we were in Wisconsin that we pronounced
it Ray Fields
I'm sorry
did you mean Raymond fields
yeah Ray Fields
yeah like it's a sports bar come on down
to Ray Fields
two for ones on admonishments this week
free drinks not just on Sundays anymore
come on down Ray Fields why watch the
game when you can be where it's decided
[Applause]
the good guys always win at Ray Fields
same Raphael's okay
and my dad was cheap he just wanted a
free babysitter he sent me to uh he sent
me to uh weekday Sunday school anybody
go to weekday Sunday School
that's next level Sunday school if you
don't know
if you don't if you don't know if you
didn't grow up in a cathedral that every
under every Cathedral there's a there's
a bomb shelter
uh where there's about
half a dozen pasty white children with
bug-eyed
and a couple nuns telling them about the
world and it's about as it's a pretty
close to a baby huff and dungeon if you
I mean it's down in there it's you know
it's kind of airtight you can smell
those kids they're down there I mean
it's just learning the same book over
and over and I was seven I was a prick
kid I didn't I have time for this I
just started wondering if trees had
Souls I didn't
I had started wondering what I wanted to
believe in in the world but I wasn't you
know they throw the they throw the book
at you they throw they throw the book at
you and then and they dangle Santa Claus
and I didn't like that felt like a
threat
and you know I walked in there my dad
was a car I didn't need to be there I
walked in like Drake dude No New Friends
what are you gonna tell me foreign
and uh the nuns hated me right away they
didn't like me I I I'm still open to
anything I'll believe in anything if
it's convenient
anything at all I I you know I I wasn't
opposed I definitely didn't know uh God
existed but I didn't know he didn't I
wasn't sure in any direction and I'm
still not out I I don't uh astrology
it's a good example I don't believe in
astrology unless
somebody doesn't like me
and then I only believe in astrology
what she said what
what month was she born in
of course she was born in November
astrology's a great religion if you need
to to explain why people don't like you
Christianity is a great religion if you
need to explain why you don't like
people
and I don't know I just didn't like I
didn't get
we didn't hit it off it wasn't a good
fit
but I made it two days the second day
was picture day and we had to draw our
favorite I was in crayons I believe in
and I was in and we had to just had to
pick our favorite Bible story and just
draw that and I was just I chose Daniel
in the lions den and I just drew Daniel
just getting chewed through by like five
Lions just oh what an idiot this guy oh
look at you dance red crayon Dan
look at you
d-o-a you are a buddy I can I know
exactly why God got rid of you look at
you buddy you have another red crayon
please thank you very much yeah let's
get this guy out of here and none didn't
like it none didn't like it at all
and uh
and then but what she really didn't like
was in the corner of the picture I drew
a picture of the Sun the the ball of
fire that gives us all life
the actual God uh
I drew a face on the sun and uh I drew
arms on the Sun going
[Laughter]
and she hated it
she hated it
she hated that I had given the son a
soul
and she took my crayons away and she
lean and she said I'll pray for you
God and I'm gonna tell him what you did
she took my crayons away which felt like
I think you should leave now and I was
like fine I'm gonna go look for a guy
that doesn't care about my crayons
no offense
Q Anon reliable religion very steady
demon heavy
Christianity hold the Christ
heavy on the demons it's just nice to
know it's there to use if I need it
if we need it you know if you ever need
to relegate a significant portion of
your fellow citizenry to demon status
you ever need to make a good portion of
the people you know murderable
it's nice to know that exists
other than that I think we handled the
pandemic pretty gracefully
I do I do think we handled the pandemic
well I do think we did I know I know we
are at each other's throats and it feels
like we're in a way worse place and in a
lot of ways we are but there was nine
billion people on the planet what the
did we think was gonna happen
I think that we handled it pretty damn
well despite how we feel about each
other I think Republicans save some of
the economy I think Democrats save some
of the grandparents and all it took was
a sincere profound resentment for each
other as human beings
[Laughter]
masks really threw people for a loop
they didn't like that I get that Matt
breath is not nice
breath does not age well
there's a reason they don't make breath
scented candles
but a plague was coming a plague was
always coming
it's it's the one thing that science and
the Bible agreed on
[Applause]
I don't think everybody should have had
to live the same
I drove across country last year
there's just so many different there's
nobody in Kansas
[Laughter]
is anybody here from Kansas
[Applause]
there it is
yeah they're here thank you for coming
is it tuia
are you both senators
[Applause]
I think Kansas is a scam
I think Kansas is a scam I think Kansas
it's just there's a lot of windmills I
think Kansas is two senators and
unlimited electricity
and I just don't think
you know there's there's a lot of places
in the country like that and if you live
out there if you live in New York yeah
wear a hazmat suit
if you live in rural Kansas
I don't think you should have to wear
pants
[Laughter]
I don't think you I don't think you
should have to wear pants but I also
don't think you should have high-speed
internet access
[Applause]
because you don't have enough that's
what my family's dealing with you don't
have enough people to bounce your ghost
stories off of people are seeing people
are in a situation where they're seeing
more people on their screens than in
real life and that's the day that's a
problem because then you don't have
anybody to go bounce these ghost stories
that you're getting blown up your
from the other side of the
planet on and you got people in
baby huffing dungeons
most people are just trying to go to the
grocery store you got people on baby
Huffy you believe in that's where I lose
you lose me on a conspiracy like
that heavy that heavy that dank
conspiracy
you know
like the you know I don't know it's the
microchip there's microchips in the back
really Mandy how many one multiple
have you done a cost benefit analysis on
this huh
how much is how much has Bill Gates
investing in mapping the route from your
duplex to the strip mall nearest your
duplex
angry I I can take angry and I can take
dumb
I can't I can't take dumb and angry
because the odds are you're angry
because you're dumb
[Applause]
and I speak from experience but
I don't know if your Boogeyman has a PHD
well then maybe you're a little bit dumb
to be this angry
I don't know it's weird
it's weird it's it's appropriate though
it's the American way you know what's
the what's the worst thing we could
possibly put in our bodies was the
dumbest thing I could cram into my head
right now it's like food it's like food
Q Anon is just what happened when pizza
restaurants started making cinnamon
rolls
[Music]
thank you buddy
and it's just the uh
the screens we're in our goldfish Bowl
it's it's uh I I the I get click bait
and just dumb online I fall for it
all the time I took my wife glamping
[Laughter]
that's some internet nonsense right
there
that is some screen based nonsense right
there if you don't know it's glamorous
camping it's it's it doesn't exist
there's no such thing it's
it's for people that hate camping and
are easily fooled by the internet and
what they do is they they put what they
do is they'll put a tarp over some wine
glasses
they put pictures on Instagram they
charge 245 a night you pay it and then
you're an for the rest of your
life
it's a constant here's some dumb
clickbait I fell for
submarine that turns into a yacht
show it to me
it was just an ugly boat
it was just an ugly boat just a
decommissioned submarine to put a
spoiler on it that was it
it was pretty sad actually
the greatness of a submarine huh he used
to do science and fight Wars
you know it's getting puked on by
Kelly's bachelorette party
this thing used to make movies with
Jacques Cousteau
oh it's got it oh it's got rims on it
don't even go underwater anymore it
can't even Flex its scientific muscles
that's the fancy part about submarine
would ever turn into a yacht whenever
Stoops so low is to turn into a yacht
what do you mean who needs science we
got money
a butterfly doesn't turn back into a
caterpillar
that Glam trip made me identify with
those dudes at storm the capital though
[Laughter]
I was just there
Glenn that was just their Glam trip
they just wanted to go away for the
weekend and pretend to do some they
weren't doing
[Laughter]
they just wanted to see a democracy that
turned into a yacht
you know what bothered me the most about
January 6th
the merch
[Laughter]
why is there merch
are you guys wearing matching hooded
sweatshirts who's selling merch at the
revolution
laughs
Abraham Lincoln didn't sell top hats
what's are we do we just lose
what barley softball team what is
who are these absentee dads on Instagram
live spending their child support money
on
on merch you got merch money how bad am
I supposed to feel you got merch money
you're you're throwing it you're
smashing up the capital so that your
Fired Guy can keep his job who am I
supposed to feel bad for here
that you're Fired Guy
can you imagine the slave mentality of
lifting a finger for the You're
Fired Guy
I for one cannot
[Laughter]
wild unreal unnecessary white trash
block party that one right there
how many golf pros you think storm the
capital
[Laughter]
not pro golfers just guys running
driving ranges somewhere
foreign
ERS in here want to set the line for me
over under
12 is Way High
12 is 12 is way high 12 is I'm Going
Under 12.
five five is a better number four and a
half or five and a half
three and a half
I'll let you change it's okay you can
change your answer you can change your
answer
I like it but I can tell I could tell
already you and me we're both bad
gamblers
[Applause]
because I would go over that but try not
but you know there was one I'm just
saying there was one
Todd
he was on his screens too much whipped
up on his screens
too much time on his phone spent Todd
too much time on his phone on the Range
was Todd
[Music]
well they did it again they did it again
he threw down his sand wedge
he folded up his collared shirts put him
in his leather travel bag the one with
his initials on it
you threw that and his escalated the one
is dead leases for him
for the first time in 35 years Todd left
Myrtle Beach
[Laughter]
[Applause]
got to DC and he laid eyes on DC and he
checked into the Marriott
and he got a good night's rest and then
he woke up and he saw they had an
omelette bar so he got the
omelette
Todd likes eggs Todd likes real eggs can
you put some cheddar cheese and
jalapenos on there thank you very much
this might be the last day Todd gets
eggs
they're trying to take Todd's eggs away
and he got a good meal in his belly and
then he skipped off to the revolution
where he met his CrossFit coach and they
slammed a cop's head in the door
and bear sprayed a congressional page in
their new Q Anon hooded sweatshirts
didn't wear a mask the one time he
should have wore a mask
[Applause]
cover up time
God
now the FBI got to go to the driving
range Todd
now they gotta come to your range Todd
I don't know
Vladimir Putin said
[Laughter]
it's easier to fool a man than it is to
convince a man he's been fooled
Vladimir Putin did not say that Mark
Twain said that
but I say that Vladimir Putin said it so
that the people that need to hear it
will listen
[Laughter]
[Applause]
it's just uh
I think oftentimes we're just at the
mercy of
deteriorating men
my I gotta because I because I
I want I've always wanted to be a
grandpa I really don't have no interest
in being a parent
I want to be a parent for like five
hours a week
the rest of it looks like y'all got
ripped off
[Laughter]
the rest of it looks like a really bad
deal but
I had something that I had something
I had something change my mind about
that recently I got a Silver Alert
uh it's an amber alert for an elderly
person
do they got him in Illinois okay right
so that's
I lost the grandpa to dementia it's not
a it's not a laughing matter but uh
I mean he was doing wild at the end
and I thought you know it makes me I I
I'd be lucky to get to that point and by
the time I do I'm probably gonna be in a
lot of pain I'm gonna be lucky to not
have metal in every joint and an organ
that I want to Chuck into the lake
and if I get to that point and the Brain
that's reminding me how much pain I'm in
every day of my life decides to shut the
up and my body gets to take a
Victory lap for an afternoon and the
children that I raised to completion
think that it's acceptable to nark me
out to the fire department
you're not dead to me but
[Applause]
shit's different now
when I can remember what you did things
are gonna be different now
I mean just take my car keys away don't
do that did you how about this
my brain shut down I'm not on the loose
like did you even look
did you even look go get your
cousins and a rope and a flashlight and
go walk around the neighbor get me back
on the patio before you start texting
Three Counties my all my information
everybody I ever knew thinks I'm out
there in my PJs
running into a curb like a glitch in a
video game
go get
your cousins and my look at my grandkids
you know what haven't bring the birthday
checks back because I'm trying to
repossess some
I wrote them checks in the amount of the
age they were turning it was adorable I
was super Grandpa okay all you had to do
was get me beer and play cards with me
and this is what I get you're out of the
will but I want you to come to the
reading because I've hired a
professional wrestler to read it to you
and tell you that you don't get my cars
and I'm leaving the house to the
stripper you don't know exists
ah that was what my grandpa was doing he
was trying to a meth head stripper
in Kentucky
he was driving across state lines
that's what he thought he was doing I
mean I don't know what he did well I he
when he was leaving he was going to
him at that stripper that's the that's
the it started good
[Applause]
and then when he got there he wrapped
his car around a tree and uh that's who
when that's when things went bad it's
it's all right dude
and that just terrifies me I just don't
want the last thing on my body that
works to be my nuts
take my car keys take my nuts if I get
to that point take my boss I'm serious
this I'm honestly about to advocate for
adult male castration I am
I'm done with my nuts now a third of the
men I've ever known could handle their
boss they're ruining a perfectly good
gender ladies if you know any man that's
functional he's working very hard to
overcome his nuts we are walking around
shit-faced on our own balls all the time
or a Ferrari engine and most men are
just a Honda Accord and we are
we are burning through tires
our whole lives our whole lives
we didn't we didn't
we didn't use the care about nuts like
this as a species we did
that's that's one
that's one thing
that I learned from the Catholic Church
they used to cut little boys balls off
so they could hit a high note in choir
yeah that's real don't don't I don't
look it I didn't do this
they were called castratos
that's what I'm saying that's where nuts
used to rank just below Christmas carols
in Latin
[Applause]
right here what percentage of your bad
decisions would you blame on your nuts
I'm giving you a chance
to excuse a lot of bad behavior
forty percent that's so low
[Applause]
either you just didn't think that
through or you you got skeletons in your
closet that
you're trying to pretend aren't there
I mean I am way up there I mean well
fine good okay fine forty percent now
imagine if you weren't there to stop
them
you'd be up in the you'd be up there
you'd be uh way up there right yeah I
don't want that
take my nuts please I don't know I think
it's a it's a it's a rough situation for
men when they get to that age and then
that's the that's the only age when we
finally trust them to put them in
positions of power this is why we have
two this is why we have two types of
leaders we got that's why we only got
two kinds of leaders what the is
wrong with him and is he okay
[Laughter]
that's it
that's all that's left
and uh
and Vladimir Putin is what the is
wrong with him that's a perfect example
he's just an old man's boss playing
games with younger men's boss just
putting younger men's balls against each
other it's a time-honored human
tradition
that's just because I mean he's his nuts
are serving drinks
our brains turn to Mush our joints eject
and our balls are down there serving
drinks the whole time Vladimir Putin's
balls are the bartender from The Shining
[Laughter]
take my nuts
dead
the second I get a Home Depot credit
card I'm good
I'm not I don't want to make some of
these horrific mistakes
the that's the real pen forget queuing
on leaf blowers is the real pandemic in
this country
if there's anybody in here sometimes I
do this bit and I see old dudes face
kind of change like I like my leaf
blower
that dude get a rake bury that
in the backyard we're not going to say
anything about it we're going to pretend
like it never happened
leave my that Glam trip was fine that
was a beautiful vacation we were on my
wife's family reunion it was actually
awesome it was ruined by a leaf blower
at 8am on Sunday morning
I was in my I was in my lean too I had
my tarp
it was me my tarp leaf blower
just
[Music]
hell no
2 45 a night what absolutely in my mind
this is some that travels with
his leaf blower
my first assumption it was not somebody
from the campsite hotels don't vacuum
before checkout I thought this was some
guy because I'm ready for you to start
carrying those things in holsters like
people
like I thought it was just some
in a way in a bagel that could not
bear the thought of being a part for
sleepover for three days and he was like
oh I'm gonna be in the woods imagine all
the things I can blow around in the
woods
and I kick my tarp open I was just I
kicked my Turbo up in my underwear I was
looking for faces
and sure enough it's a dude from the
campsite collared shirt logo and
everything I was the yelling at
employees foreign
he takes his finger off the gas for a
second
it's greased up hillbilly I swear to God
looks be dead in the face I still gotta
work though
that's what he said to me
it's gonna bounce off the back of my
skull for the rest of my life
I still gotta work at work though
I instantly stopped caring about the
leaf blower
I was instantly distracted by this blue
collar cosplay he had typed up for
himself
where he was
he was somehow we were at work right now
this dude it was a he wrote a golf cart
with a leaf blower
with a an outdoor blow dryer to point it
at some gravel Patches he drove to work
got in a golf cart brought a blow dryer
I still gotta work though you buddy
I wasn't raised in a coal mine okay but
I roofed houses and painted houses and
bale hay and I was Mr Miyagi enough to
know that taking one button to the next
button to the next button does not make
you the backbone of the American economy
guy
thank you
you are not a dock worker friend turn
that down you are ruining my Glam
trip
[Applause]
buttons thanks buttons uh
take a couple hours off go have some
more Red Bull what are you doing I hope
you don't got a kid at home playing
fortnite that you berate for not popping
out of bed every morning so go move
leaves around in the woods
it's everywhere it's going
it's Coast fornia there's no leaves
there's no leaves it's just dust it's
just dust you're just whipping up the
dust you're just whipping up dust into
the air why why
big is your lawn you better have a
football field
to justify that thing to justify
weaponizing what used to be the ground
you ever get it in your eyes it's a
and mouth and throat you shut down my
block for four hours with your
leaf blower what are you doing
and where does the dust settle cars
all your cars now all your leads all
your neighbors have to go get car washes
because you because you had to have it
you had to there there could be ranges
ranges away from our cars leaf blower
ranges I see I'm standing by this
the leaf blower ranges were coked up
step dads can go and
micromanage small patches of cement for
15 20 30 minutes at a time
just to blow off some steam whatever
fixes it whatever I want sure I want
your patch to be clean guys
but otherwise leaf blowers should cost
ten thousand dollars
and a 9 500 are actually going to a
federal fund to pay for all your
neighbors car washes past present future
I stand by that
um
all right I'll get out of here
um no there is I saw one guy in Kansas
it was the cop that let me out of a
speeding ticket with a joke
I like that guy
I was smoking weed I was in Kansas
just trying to get through Kansas I
don't care if it's legal it's legal
where I live it's legal I don't have
I don't have time to figure out who
don't have it figured out yet
I can't keep track of what states are
still run by dorks from the 50s
[Laughter]
and I wasn't even planning on my feet
touching the ground in Kansas so
I was smoking weed I was moving
a little bit later obviously the lights
on damn okay pull over this dude walks
up real tense tense guy
kind of cop
seemed like he might fire tear gas to
cover a fart
he comes in hot he's like what's in such
a hurry for California
oh I said I'm uh I'm uh stand up
comedian I got to get to Iowa tomorrow I
have a show in Iowa so why had you going
81 or 65
yeah buddy it's Kansas that's about
that's about the bare minimum I'm gonna
be going in Kansas
you want me to stop and check out the
library guy
I'm gonna need to see your license and
registration he's right here
so he snatches it goes back to his car
20 minutes later he comes back still hot
so I'm gonna need to hear a joke
[Laughter]
I didn't like that part uh
just give me the ticket Don't Make Me
Dance you got a hard job I got a hard
job we're gonna make me dance
you know I mean he knew I didn't have my
tools this is the thing there's the
things
you're very nice
you guys are very nice
you're very nice but if I followed you
back to your hotel tonight tried to tell
you about the herpes vaccine you'd be
like
uh you got a schizophrenic on the
property right now
you may want to come get this guy too
sweet
but I didn't want the ticket
so I said okay
why did the squirrel crawl into my dick
hole
his tone changed
I piqued his interest
he said I don't know man why
so he was trying to get to my nuts
[Laughter]
well he liked that joke more than you
guys did uh
[Applause]
yeah I like I like that guy I think
about that guy I appreciated him I felt
like we grew together
I think about him I worry about him
because I know he's out there telling my
joke
you can't force comedy
takes a long time he's Birch I know he's
out there just butchering my joke
in front of God knows who Bobby 81 65
California plates we give tickets to
those guys I don't see any kind of
citation here or anything chief
here
I don't give a Bobby I'm gonna need
you some see some sort of documentation
some sort of explanation report on my
desk ended today Chief I'm gonna do it
for you live
foreign
no thanks Bobby you got the right to
remain silent chief why would how come
why would why
[Applause]
a squirrel a wild Squirrel
teeth and Claws and kind of set not
your normal squirrel that you would not
be intimidated by for the sake of this
hypothetical you
you're on your toes he can do some
damage to you Jeep and he wants
something from you something from inside
you something that you care about and he
wants it bad something that a squirrel
regularly wants what would he want that
you got what would you a squirrel with
teeth and Claws and and I know
domesticated raccoon I keep under my
porch I'm talking about a wild animal
that's got a spring in his step and
coming at you faster you ain't been able
to move for a long time on you for 35
years Chief you're a slow sum he's
coming for you and he's gonna get
something from you Chief what's he want
he wants your nuts squirrels want nuts
squirrels won't not see chief he wants
your damn nuts how's he gonna get there
dick hole
squirrel coming in your dick cold chief
Bobby I'm gonna need your gun and badge
you guys have been fantastic thank you
so much for being here everybody
thank you to the Green Mill thank you
Chicago
I love you thank you
cheers everybody thank you
[Music]
okay